hello everybody and welcome to back to
big mood yeah
i just had one land one job one job
you [ __ ] it up okay erase casey can
you cut that can you
cut it
hello everybody welcome back to big mood
yeah nailed it yeah good job
we got some new faces in the house well
just one new face we got
nikki blades in the house today she will
be
guest hosting with us for four episodes
because gina's getting new boobs
and yeah she's getting a new body in a
day
they have a whole brand new body yeah
just wait so uh we have a stand-in
replacement body yeah replacement
we tried to think choose to fill for
gina yeah big big boobs
yeah big bros to fill yeah i think i got
it covered yeah you do
you've more than got it covered up i
could see them in person and they're
great
we'll
i just remember that bitcoin was just
starting to go back up you were like
it's at 16.
it was great yeah 16. we had a moment
wow
yeah because it had been down to like
three or four years
people were freaking out and then like
it broke through ten
yeah and then she's like i still have
mine it's at 16. yeah you think this is
the peak
i think currently today it's at 32
so it went to 65. yeah
people didn't even believe it was going
to break past 10 again so that was like
a big deal
you know really you know they think
you're crazy until they make money yeah
and then when they lose it they blame
you yeah you know that's how it goes
that's how it be i'm not an expert an
expert i'm not an
expert i'm not an upskirt anyway
how have you been busy okay since
did was i working in san francisco on
the radio yes you had just
left i saw i just left yeah in stockton
yeah so now i'm working in san francisco
for 99.7 now so i'm doing the morning
show out there it's called big bay
mornings
this yeah a new this is a different
radio station different radio station
yeah so
i believe i was in stockton because was
it 2020 or 2021 2020.
okay so yes so i started working at 99.7
now
january of 2021 oh congrats thank you so
new host i think everything you you were
gonna be switching over so for me i'm
like yes
yes yeah yeah we had already been like
we already been talking i think i had
already
left stockton i mean which i love by the
way is shout out to kayla and i love
them but
so now i'm in san francisco still doing
the no chaser podcast with the boys
yeah that seems to be doing really well
too huh you guys are back in the studio
yes yeah we're back in the studio tim
has a baby
you know rick don't got a baby i don't
got a baby i don't got a baby
rick can like co-parent a baby if you
probably probably might not like it
yeah is going to take that position and
i will watch i'm the auntie
yeah be a chaser baby chaser baby yeah
yeah
man that youtube channel would be
amazing can you imagine the chaser baby
imagine the revenue
you just saw yeah yeah and veda
got a system going on right now veda is
bringing in the money like i'm
thinking of onyx oh my god
like chia is like not even in veda at
all like where
how does she just create a tim clone i
think all the babies look like the dads
are
that young and then they they're going
to change it's so good dad doesn't try
to say that's kind of a baby
yeah that's actually a fact because when
isaac was
younger than a year he looked way more
like his dad yeah oh and now he's your
clothes yeah
that's crazy yeah all the babies look
like they're dads oh and just in case
you are a new listener
um nikki blades is on a podcast called
no chaser
so definitely check that out it's with
all of our friends
tim deleghetto or none chaturang sorry
and they talk a lot about la if you
think we talk about sex
uh our last episode we did a full hour
of just talking about vegas and strip
clubs and
some of the things that we've done but
now that tim's a father
it's really back it up a little bit but
his real dad like
the things that he talks about is like i
can't wait to go see so and so
so i can meet their baby i said oh
you're like who is this man did you
choose your chapter are you just
planning baby dates now and he loves
buying onesies
i don't even know he's got his baby on
baby tinder and they're trying to find
playmates i'm pretty sure that's already
arranged like there's probably a
list of babies because all of his friend
you know a lot of people are
babies everyone's having babies yeah so
that's the thing to do
yeah i guess we gotta have a baby [ __ ] i
know y'all have to try it i'll have fun
with that
i don't know it's not gonna be me that
won't be me either
that's a race life is not a
race well between me and if we're trying
to have a baby yeah
we're like the people that signed up for
a marathon and then we're at the
marathon and we're like
oh we have to like stretch and eat a
banana yeah right
we started like we're gonna walk first
and then well we'll start jogging and
yeah maybe after mile two
times if we don't finish the marathon
it's fine
exactly oh that sounds exhausting yeah
but it's flat yeah i was gonna say it
sounds like you trained for this
marathon
and just got there and decided how long
has this been
18 years of hold on wait they don't walk
right away and then they're on my health
insurance until 26. right like they
don't pay rent
it was just a few years ago where i
thought that was dope because i was 24
and i was like i
bought the health insurance until 26 and
now i'm closer to my parents age and i'm
like
oh [ __ ] this shit's going to be on my
health insurance 26.
oh you start taking regular jobs just to
have health insurance you're like look i
didn't want to work at chipotle or in
now but they got really good benefits
and that's true i know you're paying 15
an hour they do well shout out to in and
out for paying their employees i know
they do so they do so well i was like
hey baby
uh your first minimum wage job in and
out it's not minimum wage go to in and
out oh their managers make over a
hundred thousand
they do well yeah we're all going to
work for in-n-out now
oh yeah speaking of new studio we are in
a new place if you're not watching on
youtube we are
actually in my living room so it looks
like a set
yeah it's so nice nice it's so cozy too
and then like casey's now
our editor yeah that's a change this is
my husband by the way
so now we're going to yell at casey
instead of gabby yeah
it is a mood i walked in i was like ooh
yeah we've got lights lighting plants
yeah i like it it feels like our vibe
too it feels like
um we've been switching up the set like
every once a year
basically pretty much and it gets closer
and closer to like our vibe
each time yeah yeah we also might try
tiff's living room
yeah uh like we might try different
spaces
just to see yeah last year was a
pandemic we couldn't really go anywhere
but this time we get to play around and
yeah we also thought about like buying a
set but we were like
hmm this is do we want to do we want to
like buy a whole ass because we only
shoot once a month
yeah yeah so it's like oh it's just a
once a month space
yeah one day mm-hmm one day yeah well i
mean in case you guys were wondering why
we had to switch sets though it's
because our previous place they ended up
needing to use that space for other
things
so we're like oh this is a perfect
opportunity to switch up yeah and since
so jess just moved to texas we're like
maybe one day we'll do it in texas
so now we have kind of like a freedom to
move around and
switch up the set and switch up the vibe
and stuff yeah how is texas by the way
i'm honestly loving it yeah i feel so
much more relaxed there i didn't even
realize
before i left like how much i was gonna
feel better getting there because like
the whole well obviously the pandemic
was not good for anyone and that like
really raised my
anxiety levels and stuff like that but
like as soon as i got back home
um like i stopped having panic attacks
like i was able to actually go to sleep
at night like i've been
it's really been calming me down to be
there
and it's weird because it's like i i was
so emotionally attached to l.a
and i was like i can't leave i have to
be here like but then as soon as i left
then like a lot of my anxiety left
do you think and i if you've never been
to la i don't know if you've
you probably i don't know if you've
experienced this i get the same kind of
feeling in new york too
but there's a certain energy in the air
like when you
come here there's like a mixture of just
like
hyperness like everyone's hustling but
also this like underlying depression
and anxiety from people who don't know
if they're going to make it yeah
people fly from all over the country
like the best of the best to try to
to make it out here in all these
different industries entertainment
industry and sports and music and
just so many different aspects and i
feel like you kind of feel that energy
in the air
yeah i think i do and also i because i
never really wanted to come to la to
make it
yeah i feel like i don't really fit in
and so like there's a whole kind of
underlying
sort of social game you have to play
yeah to like maintain connections
network and stuff like that and then so
now that i'm in austin like the other
day i was at the dog park
and some guy brought his dog over and
then i just started chatting up with him
and he was just like
oh yeah no he's not single he mentioned
his girlfriend right away just so that
like okay probably to let me know that
just we can deal
with him hey ladies stop trying to hit
on me
i wasn't trying to hit on him but i
think he was just trying to like be like
you know you got a girlfriend but i'm
chatting you up right
yeah like me you can feel safe
we're just talking about like you know
he's like where are you from and in
texas right now it's like a very weird
thing
like if you're from california people
are going to be pissed off
right i went into the conversation like
well you know i was actually born in
austin
um i grew up like on the coast and
corpus christi you know you know where
salinas from from corpus christi
i went to college there went to college
of san antonio
yeah and then he goes oh that's cool i'm
from new york and i was like oh thank
god
now that we got that off our chest like
giving them your life story
like in middle school
i'm not a californian don't shoot me no
um yeah there's just like a weird thing
but actually a lot of people that i've
met
are not from texas so far so i'm like i
kind of have my
yeah yeah especially people that moved
in that way for a while
yeah the people that moved me in my
apartment were also like not from
texas one guy was from like san diego or
whatever like the guys that were moving
the stuff into my apartment so i was
just like okay well i haven't met any
like actual text and then i have to
explain that story to yet but i keep
feeling like it's coming because i know
like even if you look on youtube
comments about like
buying a house in austin like all the
comments are like don't [ __ ] come to
austin
it's the same way with vegas because we
were thinking about moving to vegas and
all the
comments are like don't come here we
don't want you every state
nobody wants us it's like half of your
license plates in vegas or california
because
everyone's we are your business i worry
about my car
and i have luckily have a garage in my
apartment but i worry about my car
because i'm like am i going to just come
out of the target parking lot and be
keyed or something
in california where we live in
california and worry about our cars
but like now i'm just like in my city on
the license
am i going to be like targeted for being
californian luckily so far no and i
think i'm just my guard is up because
i'm like
i'm not from california i just live
there you know like but
everyone's there's a place yeah yeah it
was a brief visit of six years
um are you gonna be changing your your
license yeah no i need you have like 60
days to like register your car or
whatever so i'm going to do that when i
get back you can get away from those
california taxes yeah
yeah but um anyway to in the dog park
story he actually
he said we actually have like a little
group going like everyone brings their
dogs like at 5pm
he goes sometimes we go to the river
together like this whole group got a
boat like a couple weeks ago and hung
out and like so they have like a little
community
we found a little river dog group yeah
so i'm like i haven't hung out with them
yet but like
hopefully that will happen and i could
meet new friends already yeah
that's another thing is la's very lonely
yeah
when people move here and they think
like it's gonna be filled it's not like
new york at all like in new york
everyone socializes they really like
the nightlife like you meet people and
people like to talk to people but
in l.a it's not like that it's just for
what can you do for me
or yeah what can i get out of it so
people find that they're very little i
never experienced the loneliness aspect
because i've always had family here
yeah um but i know a lot of people who
moved here from other states
that have just extreme loneliness it's
really interesting to hear
outsider perspective because like i was
born and raised in l.a so i don't really
see that like like how you're talking
about like there's different energy here
i
totally don't relate to that because
i've just always been consumed by it
yeah i didn't even
know that there was a different energy
do do you feel like when you go to other
places
that there's a different vibe yeah i
definitely do sense a different vibe
like when we go to dallas to go visit
casey's family
it does feel different there it does
feel like to you because now
i'm the insider of texas so what does it
feel like to you
as the outsider of texas so to me texas
feels
a lot more calm a lot warmer everyone's
a lot friendlier
um like it does throw me off sometimes
we'll go to the grocery store and people
be like hi good afternoon i'm like what
like i'm trying to sell me yeah i'm like
i'm gonna buy bananas you used to like
being talked to
um so yeah that kind of throws me off a
little bit but then also
actually the city that we currently live
in now it's further away from
like the center of la it's a lot more
small town vibes
yeah it's really quiet the outskirts
exactly yeah it's in the outskirts so
then now i'm
i'm getting used to that kind of like
warmness because i'll just go to the
starbucks drive-through and then they'll
chat me up for like 5-10 minutes and i'm
like
this is not l.a like this is weird when
i go to your
house now the neighborhood that it
doesn't have that buzz that's always in
the air in l.a like there's just like
this
calm noise that's that you don't notice
is there until you go somewhere else and
you're like it's quiet here
yeah yeah like the site like i remember
when i moved out
because i used to live in a like super
predominantly heavily
mexican neighborhood so every single
weekend we'd have like the banda going
yeah
there'd be like helicopters like [ __ ]
like just like police like all every
movie about l.a
no this is your neighborhood there's fun
houses in everyone's yards
yeah there's dogs always going it's
amazing yeah even like roosters barbecue
going
yeah all of that noise and then when i
moved
out of that city i'm like whoa it's
quiet but it wasn't even quiet
like before not like where i currently
live that is [ __ ] quiet yeah
but for me like comparing it from
southgate to like going to downey
i was like whoa it's a completely
different world
but even within la too it's like its own
little pockets it's like its own
yeah each little pocket is so segregated
yeah culture wise
and you have to drive far to get to
different aspects it's not like new york
where you can just like walk or take the
subway or whatever it's like
you need a car to get to the different
communities yeah so it's weird because i
definitely
experienced the loneliness thing being
in la obviously
relationship ended now i'm fully alone
living alone then a pandemic
obviously even more alone yeah but then
now that i'm in austin i still haven't
really done anything
social but i've it's like i still don't
feel alone
yeah yeah okay so the vibe is almost
like the pressure do you like you don't
have pressure to have to go out no i
don't have any pressure to do anything
at all
do you think it's also because you have
family there well yeah my dad is like an
hour away and i've seen him a few times
already
yeah and then i do have a friend that
lives in austin like that i've known for
like ten years you got like kind of a
home base going yeah
and in my home base if i need to eat
some food
i ordered from doordash i actually
really i really really did like the
first week i was ordering from doordash
because i found this really cute spot
like in the town next to me that has
this
pasta that's like this lovely [ __ ]
artichoke
barbecue pasta
they got ribs in it everything's
southwesterners parmesan
[Music]
artichoke chicken pasta so good i use
door dash door dash is really reliable
i actually like the interface of
doordash more than the other
apps i like the way it looks yes
technically i like the doordash app
the best now you can get grocery
essentials you need with doordash too
you can get drinks snacks other
household items delivered in under an
hour
ordering is easy just open the doordash
app choose what you want from where you
want and the items will be left safely
outside your door
with the contact list delivery drop-off
setting
with over 300 000 partners in u.s puerto
rico canada
and australia you can support your
neighborhood go-to's or choose from your
favorite national restaurants like
popeyes chipotle and cheesecake factory
for a limited time our listeners can get
25 off and zero delivery fees on their
first order of 15
or more when you download the doordash
app and enter code
mood that's 25 off up to a 10
value zero delivery fees on your first
order when you download the doordash app
in the app store and enter code
mood don't forget that's code mood for
25
off your first order with doordash
subject to change terms apply
and while you're enjoying that delicious
food your feet should also be very
comfortable if your belly's comfortable
right
yes those things go together
all right so it's 20 21 and nobody has
time for uncomfortable shoes
that's where rothy's comes in i love my
raw fees me too
freaking love them i'm so obsessed with
these shoes like i want
every single style that they have
there's so comfortable like they make
they made a soccer shoe
and i don't know how they did it but i'm
not gonna ask questions it's so
comfortable
yeah and it's awesome because they're
actually sustainably made with materials
like plastic
water bottles i love that what the heck
i don't even know how how how
do they do it i don't ask questions yeah
and they are
fully machine wash washable you need
that for them stank feet you know you in
the summer time you wear the same flats
for like a week
yeah exactly they got the foot stank on
them
gross i could smell it but not with
these
these won't be stinky forever you can
actually just throw them in the washing
machine
and they're available in tons of shapes
styles and colors so you can always find
the right one just for
you pop sugar named rothy's one of the
most comfortable and cute flats you'll
ever
wear well never tire awareness true
upgrade your closet with washable
sustainable style of shoes and bags from
rothys
plus they just launched men's shoes you
guys
oh [ __ ] you guys have no tomatoes on
there either yeah so make sure to check
them out for you
or the guy in your life head to
rothys.com
big mood to find your new favorites
today that's
r o t h y s dot com
slash big mood rothys.com big mood
okay speaking of comfortable shoes i
don't know this just connected in my
brain
but airports um you're both like flying
in
to la to do your shows i don't know how
often uh no chaser shoots
once a month okay so once a month for
both of you um
i heard i haven't been to the airport
yet since things
started opening up but jess was telling
me they don't allow drinking on planes
anymore
what what airlines girls it's uh
american and southwest
they only have um the first class gained
by alcohol on the plane but
in the terminal all the restaurants are
still open so you could drink before you
fly
but you're on american and i think
southwest don't quote me but on like two
airlines because if you've watched the
news lately there's been a lot of people
like
fi like fist fighting the flight
attendants
because when i go back to mexico i had
some red wine you were probably not on
american north southwest yeah
i flew jet blue okay which love j
i love that blue jet blue be hit or miss
sometimes it depends on the air
well so i feel like some of the
airplanes are like the older ones
i did miami to vegas on jetblue by the
way i love jetblue mint is one of the
best experiences i have had the mint
it's like their first class it's amazing
i'm talking about eating burrata
i mean salmon okay you know they got
dessert so it's an actual first class
yes i think american and delta first
class is like it's just seats in the
front
yeah it's not special at all i think
it's like sfo something with sfo we get
a lot of good planes flying out of there
so it's great it really is a better
airport
but on the way back from miami to vegas
i had
the uh i had the ghetto
plane it was the tv was this big
oh no and that's a four and a half hour
flight yeah the tv was this big the
wi-fi didn't work the tv phone has a
bigger screen the tv was stuck on one
channel
no no you know so you like the directv
thing yes they're using an engine for it
and i'm not even exaggerating it was the
size of the that's the only
one yeah it was the old school plan so
they didn't have any alcohol on there
but flying to miami they did yeah and
then also i fly jsx a lot from the bay
area to la jsx is one of the
best experiences i'm not sure if you
guys jet suite yeah so they go by
like the jsx experience or you know
joyful whatever experience
literally you go through what's the
easiest check the bagging get on you get
your cocktail
sharing a private jet yeah okay yeah and
then the prices are great
and the prices are great plane though
because i can't do small
it's not it's just a smaller it's not
like the propeller smaller what i mean
is like two rows and two rows
like it's like one and two oh yeah i
can't do those
i that's a game changer for me i'm also
gonna try it i haven't tried
yeah you should try it i mean the prices
aren't that crazy and honestly there's
two airports in san fran in the bay area
so it's really convenient i fly out of
oakland
hour flight to post like on instagram to
use that or something no they were just
doing instagram deals like
trying to influencers were like getting
free flights because i'm like why is
everyone posting about jet suite like
because they make you post no no they're
doing something
like it's one of those things when
you're walking you go into the hangars
right yeah it's not just it's not an
airport it's normally like experience
you don't even have to
get there two hours early like the 15
minutes yeah baby i should
walk right on the tarmac you go you see
your plane everybody has a rolly bags
you're wearing your glasses everyone's
living that fancy life
hell yeah every time i ride the plane
i'm like that's right
i'm gonna have my drink it's the same hi
samantha
i know once a month okay
the best thing is uh burbank airport's
only seven minutes away
and they do direct flights to yeah and
they go to vegas
now i know you live nicole excuse me
i'm sorry excuse me mom don't use your
government name
we're both called out we're not attacked
right now
it's getting serious but the airplane
words
right i got confused someone calls me
tiffany i'm like who's that
i do that sometimes i do that because i
know i i love to call you tiffany
because yours are like what's up
yeah i tried it on a desk but jessica
makes her feel sexy and i'm like yeah
that's not what i was
[Laughter]
i love you dad but yeah it just depends
on the airlines that you're flying with
but it's i mean again if you could ever
fly those ones like
that i do have to say though the
difference between lax and the austin
airport
austin airport's really small but with
tsa precheck and i keep
i keep taking like the 7 pm flight out
of austin and i literally just walk
through there's no one
in line so i can show up 10 minutes
before my flight do you use
clear does anybody here use players i
did the free trial
i had it for a year clear plus tsa
pre-check if you travel a lot which i
would say for you because now you're
going to be coming in once a month
or wherever you guys are going it is
inexpensive
too concerts sporting events
yeah they're heavily promoted with um
normally wherever american express is
doing like their thing clears there as
well
but man you just go scan scan
and when you have to tsa precheck they
take you directly to the front
of like everything and you just walk
through so tsa precheck is cutting in
the normal line and then clear is
cutting in that line yeah
and you don't ever have to when you go
through clear so clear has its own
but when you're clear and tsa you don't
pull out your id
you don't have to take off your shoes
that's dope it is a cool use your
face or something nice eyes are
fingerprinted yeah okay
but that's a game changer if you travel
a lot the combination between the two
is like you'll never go back you never
wait in line it
it changes your experience of what you
would think flying is you know the
anxiety
yeah two hours early i gotta check my
bags i gotta do that man if you learn
how to travel with the carry-on and you
have those two things
you'll wanna travel more i feel like
that's the secret that most people
are talking about it's like sponsored by
clear so if you wanna go
it's opening and you know a lot of
people are starting to go back
out and wanting to be social and
especially in the bay area right now
they're trying to get people to go out
and spend like go to these restaurants
we were on lockdown lockdown so nikki
street eats is going to be doing a thing
called bites with blades
and one of the main things i'm doing
right now is highlighting a lot of the
bay area restaurants
and the bay area actually has over like
40
plus michelin-starred restaurants yes
yeah i didn't know it was a foodie town
oh my goodness like the bay area is so
big and there's
you know napa we have napa and you go to
yachtville and you have those places not
you know french laundry's over there but
there's more but there's more places
that you wouldn't even realize
our michelin-starred restaurants and the
beauty of that because not a lot of
people understand like the michelin
rating and all that
you know it involves consistency you're
going to get a good experience the
quality of the food
and when you're going to these places
it's not always the most expensive place
so you have like a one star to three
star and actually next week i have
this spot called commiss i hope i'm
saying that right in
piedmont which is in oakland and there's
so many different places these
restaurants are at that you would never
know or you walk past them and you have
no idea that they're there
and another spot it's called raza and
it's an indian restaurant and that's a
one star so kamis is a two-star michelin
restaurant
and then raza is a one star and so i
really want to start going
well i'll be going to those places and
wanting to expand people's
idea of what going to fine dining is and
not your typical stuff like i
feel like it's date night let's go out
let's get dressed up let's enjoy
dining for what it was initially you
know like enjoy the food and enjoy this
experience like going to town which i
love towel and going to these certain
places like
they're staples catch hit catch hit
towel hit beauty and essex like they're
great
but a lot of people don't know that
there's so many other restaurants that
have great experiences
that you literally cannot get anywhere
else but from that chef
at that restaurant yeah that's the spot
on that day yeah yeah so
uh bites with blades is really going to
be heading in that direction and i'm
expanding more on that because there's
so many places la has about six
michelin-starred restaurants and then
yeah i didn't think that la would have
less than yeah
i bet vegas has a lot right biggest one
is vegas is like while the chefs go and
like
do a residency for a little bit i mainly
checked the bay because i was like cool
this is where i'm at
i really want to show love where you
know and have people go
places get out change up the scene we
don't have a like crazy nightlife in the
bay area
but our food yeah and you know the city
like inside and out so
yeah that's a good that's awesome but
checking out these restaurants i had no
idea like i
most of these places i didn't even knew
exist and as soon as i started talking
about them other people were like oh
wait like we have that here it's almost
the same reaction it's like we know
about napa
naf was like the go-to and then you know
french laundry but besides that most
people don't even realize
how much good food is out there so bites
yeah bites with blades
so it goes uh one through three and then
they also have like subcategories so you
have the ones that are more
uh depending on what you're going for
right like if you want something that's
more friendly as far as like eco they
have like an eco-friendly one like
they're using all sustainable
food you know like the way that they but
does it taste good
but it normally does yeah michelin is
going to have to have it
yeah then you have the ones that are
like these are honorable mentions
if you're not looking to break the bank
go here so yeah i do see a lot of
restaurants that have that
yeah like i forgot which it looks like
the little there's like one with the
little michelin man if you see that
that means they've gone there and it's a
good spot to go to and if you ever
want to check them out and recognize i
think it's what it's called or something
and then there's
uh like the plate with the fork and
knife that's another one that normally
means that it's really good food as well
if you look if you go to the michelin
website and you can look up the places
if you're ever visiting somewhere and
you need like
something outside of a yelp review or
just your favorite person online
hit up the michelin guide go check it
out mickey nicki street
head up nick yeah yeah yeah i'm over
here trying to help everybody
but yeah it was like my two blades is
coming soon because i was a waitress
at this uh hotel but i was like where
are all the
a-list celebrities went and producers
and all the industry went and it was
raffles la motage hotel in beverly hills
and one of our selling points was that
we were supposed to say it was a
five-star five-diamond hotel
um and a restaurant and i guess there's
only
two restaurants in all of the us
that are five diamonds and then and five
stars but i i guess you're saying it's
only three stars but
i don't know what i meant to say we said
five stars diamond is a different rating
okay so that's a different rating system
versus like both she had michelin
and the diamond yeah so we were supposed
to say
we're both like right both yeah and
diamond is that's crazy because i know
there's actually one in houston there's
a hotel in houston that's a
diamond like a five so yeah hotel hotel
restaurants usually suck
well it's the hotel this is a fine
dining french restaurant
yeah so we were so the hotel was five
diamond and the restaurant was five
stars
yeah but yeah again it's like different
guides right
like it's just different scales like you
have a
yelp versus going on something else or
you're looking at all these different
places
michelin essentially created the
michelin guide because michelin is the
tires
yeah and they were wanting people to go
out and to drive
so that's weird i'm like what are your
tires you have to do with food well
because you have to drive
so the tires you know you have to drive
you connect them to them
yeah and while you're driving check out
this restaurant
and and when you look actually that's
exactly what it is because it's like
this one you should go out the way for
so like a three-star place
the way that they should wear out the
tread on your tires like this restaurant
out of your way this is worth it a very
rocky road to get there
but it's worth it you're gonna have to
place your tires but it's working but
it's worth it
so honestly when you look at the guy
like one
two and three it's like one if it's on
the way stop there for sure
two it's a little out the way it'll be
great the experience you'll love it
three star is like i don't care where
you are in the world you have to eat
here
so that's generally how they describe it
yeah but yeah that's how they connected
the two because they have hotel ratings
and if you ever see like a michelin star
like you know that that [ __ ] is legit
yeah it's nice well now i don't have to
look because so we're going to vegas
on monday monday through wednesday um so
this would be the first time i've been
to an airport since the pandemic
happened and that's what i was asking
about the airports because i've never
flown to las vegas without a drink
because that turbulence when you fly
into
mclaren airport yeah i think it's always
bad it's always bad because they have
like some sort of
wind thing or whatever but you're always
going to hit turbulence
in denver i think need a drink in me if
i'm gonna yeah i'm gonna go through that
that's a short trip that's a short it's
45 minutes yeah it's
it's like cake you go up they give you a
drink then you go down yeah
okay so i love those flights yeah so if
you're gonna go to vegas
yeah check out berries i just went to
berries it's off the strip
the food is amazing the service is
amazing i posted up a video on nicki
street
oh [ __ ] okay you even do uh do the bone
marrow luge
oh i don't eat me but never mind don't
do that he's a vegan so i will
i don't know i
there's one out here but they that's
really good over there okay where did i
go
uh nobu teppanyaki they can do
vegetables
okay okay we're gonna look i'm gonna
have to have a vegan addition
yeah i'll eat fish um i'll eat seafood i
don't eat uh crust
or i don't eat crustaceans okay so no
crab
no mussels no oysters oh oysters are
different those are mollusks
so you're real technical that's gonna be
like
the like the crabs like the roaches yeah
yeah no lobsters or crabs
yeah those are like this roaches of the
sea uh no shrimp but i mean i'll each
i'll make them
okay now we're going to need a list
okay so basically i was like i'm
pescatarian but then i found out that
lobsters like hold hands under the sea
and they mate forever and i'm like
i could never eat that again and then i
found out that oysters don't have a
central nervous system so they
like there's a debate on whether or not
they feel pain but okay you know oysters
are pretty
sea urchin good uh i know i just just
straight up like oh that's just a no
no okay got it what about octopus oh no
those are smart yeah those are too smart
and they're so protective the mothers oh
my god
could never i need a little list yeah
i'm going to start going through
looking different you don't react you
don't have a nervous system
don't tell her that she's going to
listen i'm a fish murderer okay if you
want to call me a monster for that
i'm a monster i'm over here all the
animals
i realized i had no vegan options which
i'm gonna have to go check out
they have really good vegan restaurants
they're any michelin star restaurant
that's vegan
totally vegan probably they or maybe
in vegas their buffet has a whole vegan
section that's like they got vegan crab
cakes they got vegan like they do like
really good
oh so you want to eat [ __ ] animals
but you want to without eating the
animal yeah because i have compassion
for a living being i'm sorry
just [ __ ] yeah it's not like i don't
like the flavor of it
i'm gonna hurt your feelings uh the
michelin restaurants probably don't have
that vegan option most of the places are
like
this is what we're feeding you said i'll
murder a fish i said i'm i'm bad okay
i'll murder a fish
in the club you can't get the brand you
know or whatever the fish oh ranzino's
bomb
yeah i love branson now i gotta go find
vegan restaurants is it sugar terrier
is it uh sugar taco strawberry taco
it's a vegan restaurant i've heard of
sugar i want to say a couple girls that
i follow on instagram
yeah a girl that i'm friends with is
yeah investor
mm-hmm oh sugar
oh is that what it means i don't know
well it's all girls
pink tacos it is all girls pink taco was
founded by lesbians
pink taco yeah sugar taco though the
sugar
freaky ass little pizza all right you're
nasty i want some of that sugar
i you know what it's down the street
we're going to go get some sugar talking
about lunch okay you don't know what
kind we're talking about
at this point talking about i know when
you came in
she pointed out our cameras yeah she was
like wait these are the porn cameras
yeah the people i'm around all the time
i never know what i'm getting myself
into at this point i spotted the cameras
i said
look if these lights go out all the way
down we do have the mood lighting too
yes
and we blocked the windows yeah but i
looked at it and that's that freaky
camcorder like it's
mobile you know like we could take it
off the stand
for your hands like we get a first
person perspective
and then i was like oh we don't have to
wear shoes i was like oh y'all are real
nasty
bringing out the toes and you got liquor
over here this looks like
you're comfortable right like it's it
started off as a podcast we're trying to
make you stay
you guys invited me over it's no longer
a full day
now it's a podcast the location changed
sorry
we have to do it at my house now it's
like okay no worries
oh by the way this is going on our
patreon yeah
and you know you're okay with the little
nipple right just a little i brought the
toes today that's what i was
okay okay toes is good i painted them
it's like a half an areola i wore a bra
today so the temperatures
you know we you wear bras sometimes
okay i'm around dudes a lot oh true you
know what i'm saying
yeah puppies just hanging and for the
most part i'll let them swing
no i just be letting them swing yeah you
know they look sometimes it looks better
i feel like natural like natural boobs
and some dresses or tops look way better
without a brush i agree but i think this
one if it's cut like this
yeah some weird you know or i've tried
the tape sometimes i have to tape them
together
i couldn't figure it out yeah it was
hard let me tell you
don't
if you tape it to try to get cleavage
mama you are doing it wrong
i've never done it because i don't know
okay she's like folded her boob
picture you got the tape on the bottom
part and then you try to pull that [ __ ]
up does it fold the skirt
you lift yeah it's lifting see this is
the [ __ ] that the podcast started on in
the girl chat
things that girls don't talk about
going through yeah so i have this one
that has like a drawstring
that oh yeah actually rick gave me one
of those
why is rick doing giving you a bra yeah
so rick you got
so funny he actually got i guess like a
sponsorship or something for that bra
and i didn't get it i think this is
before you came to tips i got a
sponsorship but
try this one just seriously take a
picture instead of 20 years ago i think
because i mentioned it when he came on
to jk news he ended up saying like i
said oh i've always wanted to try those
yeah oh i have one i'll give it to you
yeah that is right before you came
around but very weird
i'm going to interrupt it just for one
second to shout out our sponsor
lucy which is a tobacco alternative
oh so i used to be a smoker alongside i
was a woman no well lucy is a woman
but this brand is a tobacco alternative
and it's a the company was founded by
caltech scientists and former smokers
looking for a better and cleaner
nicotine alternative
finally tobacco alternatives that don't
suck
researched and developed for three years
to be made for people not
patients lucy has nicotine gum as well
as lozenges
they come in different flavors like
wintergreen cinnamon pomegranate
citrus mint there's all different stuff
you can go look it up also one thing
that's
pretty cool about lucy is that it's fsa
and hsa eligible so you can spend your
pre-tax dollars on them so
you know obviously to get healthier your
insurance is like hey
like stop smoking try this gum try these
lozenges like it's way better for you
then smoking also
you know just try to quit altogether
it's convenient and discreet the
products can be enjoyed anywhere on
flights at work on the go
it's a subscription so a lucy
subscription comes directly to your door
each month
so it's not like you got to go to the
gas station and be all embarrassing
can i get a pack of cigarettes uh you
know
you don't have to leave your house
because lucy has delivery down
um so yeah when i quit i was using
um some lozenges i didn't even know
about lucy back then i quit like a
couple years ago
and that definitely helps curb the
cravings so i think
you know obviously it's 2021 no one
should be smoking anymore at this point
like
we should be you all need to quit
no don't face
it's 20 21 get rid of your cigarettes
they're gross unplug your vape it's also
not good for you throw out your dip
that's really nasty get some lucy
nicotine gum or lozenges go to lucy
dot co and use promo code big mood to
get 20 off all products in your first
order including gum or lozenges
that's lucy.co and use promo code big
mood
at checkout warning this product
contains nicotine derived from tobacco
and nicotine is an addictive chemical
head over to lucy.co and be sure to use
that promo code big mood for 20
off and uh while you're ridding your
body of all those carcinogens
and vape chemicals why don't you get
some supplements and vitamins to go with
your
with your new healthy physique uh ritual
vitamins are the vitamins that i have
personally been taking me too
way before the yeah sponsored the show
six years ago i think i started taking
that or not that maybe when they came
out with
four years later 2017. yeah
four week in math yeah four years ago
i love ritual just first of all the
experience of you open the bottle
and you smell them and it smells like
mint they're so cute and they're so
cute you can see these noodles are
citrus yes i've been on the prenatals
for
the past year maybe we need to talk
about wine um well we talked about
like us being in a marathon prenatals
are like
okay we're we're in the race we're using
our shoes
for the marathon it's actually made my
look at my nose same
look at that my nails are so much longer
your nails were so bad last year
yeah they really did help because we
were in the same position where our
nails kept breaking and
prenatals really do in the hair too yeah
and also you don't have the best hair
oh yeah i was reading that even if
you're not trying to have a baby if
you're over 30 you should just be taking
prenatals because it just
the folic acid and then these like
ritual specific prenatals is
amazing too because they're not hard on
your stomach like i've i've tried other
prenatal vitamins yeah they're just
really hard to digest or like they
constipate you and it's just
it doesn't feel good like all right
later on i could smell it like ritual is
it sounds amazing it's a terrible
experience you guys don't know what we
go through
yeah they also have a delayed release
capsule so it delivers high quality
nutrients including
vitamin d3 and just two daily pills and
it's designed with your live stage in
mind so like we said we're on uh the
prenatals there's also the regular one
the multivitamins and then they have
ones for
kids too yeah isaac's taking them are
they adorable no they they look just
similar
okay but they're afraid yeah yeah growth
you know yeah those kids are growing
yeah he loves them because healthy
he's 13 now so he's like i don't want to
be a little kid and and
chew gummies steve still chews the
gummies
i have to admit i do have some gummies
gummies too gummies are fine but i guess
i differentiate yeah
i'm a big kid yeah so isaac's loving
them and they're delivered to your door
every month you don't have to go
anywhere
you just get it you have to leave your
house okay just get it delivered to you
and it's easy that way like you don't
have to remember to go re-buy them
and you can also snooze or cancel your
subscription at any time and if you
don't live ritual
within your first month they'll refund
your first order so you can try it for
free no you know no risk involved
get key nutrients without the bs ritual
is offering our listeners 10
off during your first three months visit
ritual.com
big mood to start your ritual today
ritual dot com slash big mood
what were we talking about what have you
been up to nikki oh i launched a jewelry
line
oh yeah and all of you are getting your
jewelry
i'm wearing one of them right now yeah
jess is wearing one i'm wearing one
these have not been released yet but
um yeah i started a jewelry line in 2018
but it wasn't like i really want to
start a jewelry line and i was like
putting a lot of thought into it
there was this company that approached
me and was working with a lot of
youtubers at the time and so it was kind
of like a one-stop shop it was their
website they had other youtubers listed
kind of like teespring or like a merch
site right and then you get to design
the jewelry so i really had fun with the
creative process
of designing the jewelry and making it
very personal so i do cats and crystals
because i collect crystals and i like
the medium
cat lady and cat lady yeah and then i
have the
perfect jewelry a lot of cat ladies
in this group um but yeah i have four
cats so i'm probably the cat ladies
yeah i actually like your i'm not i'm a
dog person but i still really like your
jewelry like oh yeah
even though i don't have any cats i'm
like this is still cute it's still cute
and it and it's classy and it's
minimalist and yeah i just love the
i like having reminders throughout the
day so the [ __ ] perfect jewelry is like
i'm a recovering perfectionist and i
feel like
sometimes it gives me anxiety or i won't
even start something because i want it
to be perfect before i start
and you just gotta get that out of your
head and so having that reminder
like really helps so i started it in
2018 with this company
and then it was going really well i was
really excited to continue developing
stuff the packaging is really cute and
they were doing everything i didn't have
to think
and then they just disappeared like
mid-2019 maybe we were in the middle of
development for actually this
line this exact stone uh for cats and
crystals because we release a different
crystal each time and then it's gone
forever um
and they just disappeared they stopped
returning texts they they had paid me my
last check
but i never heard from them again i
tried several times
no idea the website disappeared
their socials
have no idea what happened apparently
they had been in business for like 20
years so i trusted them
but anyway i won't you know i'm not no
i'm not going to shade that company but
um i didn't know what to do like i was
like okay well i guess the line's dead
whatever it was just like a merch line
and so many people were like asking me
like when are you gonna bring your
jewelry back when you're gonna bring it
back and i was like i have no idea how
to start a jewelry line like that was
completely taken care of by this company
yeah
and um in the pandemic it was like oh
well i have all this time and people are
asking me for
this jewelry you know i'm just gonna i'm
just gonna try i'm just gonna google it
like start from scratch it's an industry
i'm completely unfamiliar with
but i'll just kind of use what i was
doing with that company as a template
right use that same agreement what their
jobs were what my job was the way that
we communicated and see if i can find
another manufacturing company
that's willing to take the place and i
have like numbers so there's like proof
of concept
and you know of that that kind of stuff
but yeah this time around it's been a
real ride i'd full-on did cold calling
like was calling
just like random manufacturers had
different routes i could go like
girl boss [ __ ] right now like ground up
so but now i feel more ownership over it
yeah
so it feels actually better launching
this time around where i feel like this
is my
line not like oh i have some merch on
the side yeah right
and so i've done everything from like
the logo design hiring the logo designer
the graphics the website
the packaging i had to completely
redesign um
doing all the all the creative stuff
with designing the jewelry
i did the instagram theme like i went
full out like
i'm starting a brand now and it's so
different and it's so refreshing
because i've always been the face of my
brand and i kind of like
not being the face of my brand like just
having a separate
brand but it's been a completely
different ride like i feel like such a
beginner and i'm learning a lot and
have you had a launch already yeah it
launched june 25th
was our first collection at that point
yeah
i'm sorry i didn't advertise a lot like
i just advertised on my instagram and on
my vlog channel like
last time the first time it launched i
had my my main channel and i was doing
videos about it but this time i just
i just wanted it to be like a soft
launch and
like i i was happy that people were
super excited about it but i wasn't like
trying to be all out like i just kind of
wanted to see what the interest level
was like
and people were really interested we
sold out of pretty much everything
except for the earrings um
there's still some earrings left if by
the time you're listening yeah if you
want to snag something but
that collection i don't know if we're
gonna drop it again the collections are
super limited stock
i just want it to be like if you got it
you got it and if you didn't
you missed out um see i don't like that
because um i
got some of stacy's line and then one of
the bracelets broke and i'm like
[ __ ] [ __ ] like sell me the bracelet
again and she's like well sorry that
stock's out but i'm like
i'll make it available again so what i
think i'm going to be doing
is releasing similar items like so if we
did drop another [ __ ] perfect collection
yeah
it would still be the same branding but
it would be a little different like you
wouldn't get the same exact
bracelet or ring or a necklace uh just
get sad because if something breaks or
gets lost and it's like well i want i
want to buy it
yeah what can i buy maybe yearly like
you know
maybe like in a couple years yeah it's
kind of like this thing where
there's so many ideas that i want to do
and create
and so i can't just keep restocking the
same thing
and also like i want people to know that
that
it's limited stock and you have to get
it like now and then that and if it's
gone
it's gone yeah um but yeah i mean maybe
once it grows into a much bigger company
or whatever if it gets it'll be the next
kendra scott [ __ ]
yeah how good does it feel to have
people
ask you about something that you that
you were almost like uncertain about at
one point
that you were a little bit like hesitant
you're like i want to do this but i'm a
little nervous and then
you do it in an experiment and then you
know you kind of think ah nobody's so
much more exciting and then they ask and
they're like where's the jewelry where's
the merch where's this yeah
yeah what about the are are you doing a
candle line because i know i got it so
i don't know yeah cause basically this
the jewelry line is like an extension of
me um it's just like things that
i feel remind me of home like that's why
i like every piece to have some meaning
and not just be like a random jewelry
piece um
so eventually what i would really like
is it to be
an eclectic like almost like a lifestyle
line
not just jewelry but there's candles
there's maybe wallpaper
there's like home decor pillows
cute pillows that you see me doing in
vlogs that
are like what i love to do um
that you can have in your home too so
i've yeah i've been doing a lot of
candle making and there's certainly
enjoying it
and like this is my signature scene i'm
just gonna throw this out there you know
do with it what you wish
what if you had a cat
shaped crystal in the candle so when it
melted
you can have it and then you can just
just name one after me and i'll be happy
yeah it was an idea not the ring but i
had a crystal
candle line that i was gonna do where
each one had like
i remember you telling me about this cat
shape
crystals yeah it's already your brand
and then throw that just give me just
give me one sent me just
you know what i'll say love nicky at the
bottom you got to say
footage as evidence this episode's never
gonna come out all of a sudden this
piece is completely cut out
like the heart will kind of be like a
bee no no no no
no i'm gonna
start a vlog so i need you to go back to
2021 when i gave this idea and i said it
has to be named
july 2021. currently sending this to my
lawyer because she's a billionaire
with my content right casey cut this all
of this
i'll find where someone lives what's up
infiltrate the system
yeah so it's been a new ride just
completely different from
content creation well different type of
content creation i've been having so
much fun with it
and then i've also been addicted to
poker which yeah you have
a full degenerate level yeah yeah like
daily poker
like not just poker yeah holding but
like memorizing charts
by positions like doing that the crazy
like what like not counting
like on the level of that obsession yeah
like being able to read
your opponent's range by what they're
playing what they're betting the level
they're betting at
how much they're betting i got pretty
good at card reading like knowing
exactly what cards they have
have you been to a card room yet yeah
yeah yeah i've been going to commerce
well yeah so you'll catch nikki
ecommerce now you know where she lives
you know where she spends her time no
she's like
she's like come play me give me you know
she's going to be wearing a
glasses a mustache
headphones it's like every like a harley
jack player
she's gonna have a hoodie with
headphones and glasses
i actually told steve that my 10 year
plan is to be like a cougar ass 40 year
old with the
fake big fake boobs and just like i'm
going to start smoking now so and then
i'll get all these chest rings
get the chest wrinkles and then stop
smoking yeah the whole experience
get the voice going you got to make
those men take absolutely gucci glasses
reflective
[ __ ] pocket some celebrity wore
reflective glasses
[Laughter]
yeah she thought she looked cute
back a few years on that one i have like
fake reflections of pocket aces
next level you know look at you she's
like she has aces every time
every time damn i'm betting nothing you
actually that wouldn't work in your
favor
no it wouldn't work in your phone you
know what we'll talk later
we'll talk later anyway wow that hour
flew by tiff we didn't even
really say anything that you did i can't
just should we like
yeah let's let's get it yeah let's give
tiff a few yeah exactly
so anyway stiff might have some really
interesting absolutely i don't know
who knows i mean i know so um um
what have you been doing speaking of
reading cards i don't know what's i
can't read your cards
you've been reading anything well
i'm pretty sure by the time this video
is out um
a lot of people that follow my tiffin
case channel will already know this news
but i am no longer with jk news i
haven't been
hosting for a few months now since what
like april or
um last time you phoned like early march
april
yeah when i was there was was that the
last time i think we both
no no i don't think it was the last time
but yeah it was like early april
and you know i was i i go
more into detail and on my channel if
you want to hear more
details about that but just overall
cliff notes is
super grateful that i was able to be a
part of that company for so long almost
a decade actually i started working with
jk
in 2012. but i didn't get officially
brought on to the
to the crew until two years later so
like 24. nine years that is almost
okay yeah so yeah but unfortunately like
it wasn't my decision but i'm no longer
with just getting news
so she's gonna be pouring all her energy
yeah you'll see me
i almost thought you said porn
i was like wait you didn't tell me the
porn you want to watch the podcast
you gotta come back this is what the
cameras are for
yeah you keep trying now you know she
caught on
really fast i'm trying to slowplay it
but yeah you'll see me on tiffin case
and here on big mood and that's where
i'll be spending all my time and energy
how do you feel about it i feel good i
feel like it was
just time yeah it was time because even
though i said
like like i said it wasn't my decision
it was
um it was pretty much like coming yeah
like i i felt myself out like
grow away from what the channel has been
but i stuck it out because i
have a lot of love for the company and
not everything has to last forever like
how many people actually stay ten years
at the same
time not a lot of people really do that
exactly
exactly so like i i have been feeling it
for
a few years like oh i i don't really
blend in as much like i'm not in my
early 20s anymore yeah like it's just
not
my same it's not your comedy style it's
not my same mentality so
i just um kind of just grew apart and
yeah
yeah and that's life that's exactly
that's not shocking that's just life
like
[ __ ] like that happens yeah yeah so
i mean i'm obviously gonna miss it i'm
definitely gonna miss it because it's
really fun in that room and yeah like
just having that be part of my life for
such a long time it's definitely
changing that show it's almost like the
identity is like
tiff is the host yeah yeah so it's gonna
be different
but yeah like i guess now
now that it's more like like solidified
now i guess is
why i'm talking about it but it's been
a slow like pulling away
like a slow leaf since april yeah
so yeah now we're in july so a long time
i haven't said anything
but yeah i mean i feel good i'm excited
for whatever
else may come because life changes it's
like a new chapter yeah
and i'm looking forward to what we can
do with big mood what what else we can
do with our channel and
what else happens in life so it sounds
like that's kind of a
theme for all of us right now it's like
new chapter yeah
turn the page we're ready let's go yeah
gina got new boobs so
yeah let's go she's literally waiting
for her right now
and a nine-to-five job yeah gina's now
the first one of us
yeah to have a full-time 40-hour week
job
yeah and that's exactly why i'm filling
in because i have a job
that's so crazy i got boobs you got a
real job
maybe that's the key you need boobs and
you get a real chocolate
chest [ __ ] after you get that cpa
license
then you're gonna get moving make
partners
we kind of balance each other i got the
boobs and like you're gonna
get the real job yeah yeah yeah
yeah i'm too scared to get fake ted so
they look good
you're poker playing you're going to get
them yeah yeah yeah yeah
big titty poker player lady that's our
titty poker player lady can we get that
on a shirt you know my instagram handle
yeah
you better hurry up and take that one
big titty poker lady
would be a really cute such a good old
lady brandon
you can take that for your whole life
yeah that's dope that's great
i want to be her i want to be her too
yeah you should be
her i'm going to that's my 10-year plan
guys you know i'm very goal-oriented so
it's gonna happen we're here to like you
know let the girls know what they should
strive for in life right
big titties play poker thanks for
watching and listening thank you nikki
blades for being here
filling in tune in next week and the
next three weeks
to have her on our set for all four
weeks and
subscribe if you haven't already go to
our instagram
check us out go to nicki street eats
go to no chaser and we will see you next
time
bye